SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE HERE MOVING INTO THE
SUMMER AND FALL WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE JOINED AS
WITH ACTIVATED TAKE CARE SOME
HOUSEKEEPING BUT BEFORE WE DO
WHAT WE SAID WAS A QUORUM.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE HAVE
TWO VERY SPECIAL PEOPLE ONE A
LITTLE AFTER ONE ON THE RIGHT
TODAY EACH OF THEM HAVE
BIRTHDAYS I SAW THE WE TO GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE MISLAID
GESTURE AND JONATHAN IS WELL MY
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THEM IS
LANCASTER.
WE'LL BE DOING FOR THE BIRTHDAY
HERE TODAY.
WORKING HEY THERE YOU GO HI DAY.
BECAUSE IN -- ANYTHING GOOD ON
THE BIRTHDAY.
ALL YOUR LIVING THE DREAM.
PARTY ANIMALS ALL RIGHT I LIKE
IT.
EXACTLY IT'S EITHER AGO.
HEY THERE IS.
HOW MAY NEVER HOSE?
KID AGAIN.
HI DAY IS LIKE JUST A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
THE CHOIR HERE GUARD PRESENT
MORE LOCKED.
MORE LIKE PRESIDENT BELL.
THEY'LL PRESENT HERTZBERG
RESTRICT PRESENT HER TITLE
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE ALSO BY THE DEFENSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS AN WIENER
DO YOU THINK THAT WE HAVE A
RICARDO LARA AWARD WINNER HERE
TODAY -- AND SHE IS NOT HERE YET.
SO THAT IS A FANTASTIC
MISSTATEMENTS FURTADO.
IF HE'S GONNA BE THE WINNER
ABSOLUTELY.
AAC THEIR AGO.
THAT'S RIGHT.
EXACTLY ALIKE [inaudible]
A LAZY GERMAN -- WE'D LIKE TO BE
A TO TAKE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
UP THIS TIME WE TWO BILLS
CONSENT COUNTER.
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN AND THEN ALSO ITEM NUMBER
TEN WHICH IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE BILL FROM
pAB.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER MORLOCK.
MISSING JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHY I READ MORE LOCKED.
WELL LIKE I BILL.
BELL I HERTZBERG.
WITH REGARD RICARDO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER [inaudible]
THURMOND.
ANTON SENATE WINNER CENTER
WIENER.
CAN THINK COUNTER THEIR AGO.
HI.
I THAT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN AFTER MR TAHOE.
THEN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE TODAY A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AT THAT
BILL WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY IT
WILL BE RESCHEDULED AT AN
UPCOMING DATE ITEM NUMBER. THREE
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR MASON
GENERAL OR WELCOME MEAN.
INCREDIBLE AUTHORED TO COMMITTEE
THIS IS THAT SOME NEVER BONTA.
ON A. B. AT TWO TWELVE THIS IS A
COMMON SENSIBILITIES BRING FOR
MISTER BONTA THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR.
WELCOME [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE STAFF OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY.
CURRENT GOVERNMENT CODE IS
OUTDATED AND ONLY ALLOWS LOCAL
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S AND RECORDERS
TO USE AN INEFFICIENT AND COSTLY
PROCESS WHEREBY DOCUMENTS ARE
PRESERVED BY MICROFILM.
AN ELECTRONIC SOLUTION IS BETTER
SUITED TO MANAGE CURRENT NEEDS
AND CAN EASILY STREAMLINE THIS
PROCEDURE THIS BILL UPDATE
CURRENT LAW.
AND GRANT COUNTY RECORDER'S AND
ASSESSES THE NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY TO USE EXISTING
FUNDS FOR NEWER METHODS OF
ESSENTIAL WORK RECORD
PRESERVATION LIKE CLOUD
COMPUTING STORAGE.
AND ELECTRONIC DATA IMAGING I
HAVE WITH ME HERE ROB GRASS
CLOSER WITH THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE A FEW
REMARKS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE BONTA GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
GOOD MORNING I GUESS WELCOME.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS ROB
CHRIS CLOSE REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AB TWO ONE
TWO THIS MORNING.
I ALSO REALLY LIKE -- TO THINK A
SUMMER BONTA FOR BEING A
CHAMPION IN LOOKING AT WAYS
LOCALLY THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
GOVERNMENT POSSIBLE MICROPHONE
IS AN ANTIQUATED TECHNOLOGY.
AND SO AND THE COST CONTINUE TO
GO UP AS IT'S NOT TOO AVAILABLE
THESE DAYS -- LOOK FOR TO YOUR
SUPPORT IN HERE.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
I TURNOUT WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE TO THE
MICROPHONE AT THIS TIME GIVE US
YOUR FIRST AND LAST AN
ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING NICOLE ORNAMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOAL GOOD
MORNING.
MORNING JOSH DUGGAR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WHO IS IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL NOW LIKE VISITORS
ANYONE WHO'S OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE AT THIS
TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSE.
IT'S BRING BACK TO COMMUNITIES
IF ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER VICE CHAIR MORNING SIR.
MISTER CHAIR JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION -- WHEN I SERVED AS
COUNTY TREASURER WE COULD ONLY
CHARGE FEES BASED ON ACTUAL COST
BUT FEES CHARGED BY CLERKS?
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
SO WE FOUND THAT OUR CLERK
RECORDER WAS ALWAYS SORT OF
FLUSH WITH CASH -- SOLOMON ASK
THIS QUESTION AND THAT IS ONE OF
YEARS LET THIS DOLLAR GO.
BECAUSE YOU'RE PROBABLY MAKING
MORE IN FEES THEN YOUR COSTS
CORRECT. EIGHT IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION SENATOR AND IT DEPENDS
ON THE DAY OF THE MONTH OF THE
YEAR -- AS THE MARKET GOES SO
GOES RECORDING AND RECORDING
COSTS CAN FLUCTUATE SO AT TIMES
THE RECORDERS IN THE RED AND AT
TIMES ARE IN THE BLACK DURING
WHEN THE ECONOMY'S GOING UP
USUALLY IT'S PRETTY WELL.
THIS IS A DEDICATED FEED THE
CAN'T BE USED FOR ANYTHING BUT
FOR THE ARCHIVING OF RECORDS AND
IT'S AN ONGOING THING THAT
HAPPENS EVERY DAY AS DOCUMENTS
COME AND THEY HAVE TO GET IMAGE
AND THEN PUT ON MICROFILM -- WE
HAVE HAD SOME EFFICIENCIES WHICH
IS WHY HE IS BEEN THE SAME
AMOUNT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
WE HAVEN'T HAD AND HAVE COME THE
LEGISLATURE ASKING FOR THAT
DOLLAR TO GO UP TO TWO OR THREE
AND SOME OF HIS VISION SEES HAVE
BANNED FOR EXAMPLE LIKE CHRONIC.
RECORDING NOT TITLE COMPANIES
AND OTHERS CAN GET APPROVED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ELECTRONICALLY OR COURT
DOCUMENTS WITH US EXISTING
PROCESS THE MANDATES OF THE TAKE
THAT IMAGE.
BUT IT ON MICROFILM.
AND THEN PUT IT IN A SAFE IN A
MOUNTAIN SO TO SPEAK -- THIS
EFFICIENCY KEEP THAT THAT THAT
DOLLARS OR NOT COMING BACK TO
WHAT IS THE ADDRESS FOR MORE
MONEY.
BUT YOU ARE DEDICATING AND AND
SEGREGATING THAT DOLLAR IN YOUR
IS LISTEN RECORDS 100% DEDICATED.
YES.
RYAN ASKED ME TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU RYAN.
WE HAVE NOT.
PLEASE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY THE MAJORITY LEADER
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- BOTH TO THE
VICE CHAIR RIGHT GRASS IN THE
QUESTIONS -- ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS JIM AGAIN THIS IS A
MOTION OR TO THE DO PASSED TO
THE FLOOR MR BONTA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSER AS YOU SAID
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THEM EVER
MISSING JUST A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HIGH REGARD RICARDO.
HELLO HI NIELSEN.
YES AND I WINNER.
WE ARE ALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I CHáVEZ
LIMóN THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLES SEVEN VOTES.
REFER MALARIA AND THE POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF THANK
YOU MY POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE IS.
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION -- THE NAME OF A
FORMER MEMBER SENATOR NOW
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA MISTER CHAIRMAN YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER WE HAVE A VERY
SPECIAL PRESENTATION TODAY -- MR
MAJORITY LEADER -- AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT THE
RICARDO LARA AWARD WINNER WITH
THE THE PRICE PLEASE.
I DON'T ABOUT PRISON THE PRIZE
BUT I'D LIKE TO MAKE THE MOTION
THAT THE THE AWARD WINNER WHEN
THAT AWARD YET I JUST THE THIRD
TIME I THINK I WORE IT WANTED
ONCE SHE'S DEFINITELY LEADING
THE WAY -- WELL AS THE RICARDO
LARA AWARD WINNER LAST TO COME
TO COMMITTEE -- EL FAVOR --
MISTER TODD -- RECEIVING THE THE
AWARD FOR THE DAY CAN WE SIGNIFY
BY SAYING AYE AYE -- WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER -- WHO
IS THERE?
HAVE A FAVOR. FOR THE RECORD AT
HOUSING COMMITTEE YESTERDAY --
THE CHAIRMAN DID WIN THE MIKE
MCGUIRE AWARD FOR BEING THE LAST
PERSON TO ARRIVE AT HOUSING JUST
FOR THE RECORD.
THANKS WIENER THERE YOU GO.
HI DAVE.
SO FOR THAT -- WAS MAJORITY
LEADER I THINK WE HAVE A
TRADITION WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
AUTHORS IN I THINK -- FOR THAT.
ONE BUT WE DO HAVE AN EYE ON MY
GOSH THIS IS NICE TO SEE YOU I
APOLOGIZE HIDING AS I'M LOOKING
OVER THIS WAY I POLICY SO THE
WOMAN PLEASE COME ON COME ON
FORD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BEFORE THE IF
SOMEONE PRESENTS A WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ADD -- THE RICARDO
LARA AWARD WINNER ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR GIVE US ONE
MOMENT WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU.
THIS IS THE CARILLO CENTERS BILL
IT IS [inaudible]
NO NO.
IN A MOMENT IF YOU DON'T MIND US.
WE'RE GONNA ADD MISTER TITLE ON
TO THE CONTENT COUNTER MISSING
JUST IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THAT IS THE A SEVEN ZERO
VOTE THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE ON THAT.
WE WELCOME THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN TO
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE ALL OF
HER WORK WE'RE NOW FOCUSING AN
ITEM NUMBER FOR A BI LEVEL SIX
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IT'S GOOD TO SEE
A FIRST TIME IN FRONT OF
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU FELT WELCOME MISTER
CHAIR GOOD MORNING TO YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ON ELEVEN OH SIX THE
HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
WHICH HAS BEEN SERVING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HOMEOWNERS AND
TENANTS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE ENHANCED
HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
WAS ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TO COMBAT THE EFFECTS OF
THE MORTGAGE CRISIS.
IT HAS ALLOWED THE COUNTY TO
EXPAND SERVICES TO HOMEOWNERS
THAT INCLUDE COUNSELING SUPPORT
TENET RELOCATION SERVICES AND
LOAN MODIFICATION ASSISTANCE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK
OF THE PROGRAM BY EXTENDING THE
SUNSET.
TO TWENTY THIRTY AND HELP KEEP
COUNTY RESIDENTS IN HOUSING.
WITH ME TODAY IS BRIAN STEIGER
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WANTED
US TO TURN MEMBERS -- BRIAN
STICKER REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSOR WITH FROM THE BILL.
ELEVEN OH SIX THIS BILL WOULD
SIMPLY EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE ON
AN ENHANCED PORTION OF A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THE HOMEOWNER
NOTIFICATION PROGRAM.
THIS UNIQUE PROGRAM HELP
DISTRESSED HOMEOWNERS SAVE THEIR
HOMES FROM FORECLOSURE AND
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS FROM BECOMING
VICTIMS ARE FRAUDULENT
FORECLOSURE CONSULTANTS.
ALTHOUGH THE RATE OF
FORECLOSURES HAS SOMEWHAT LEVELS
SINCE THE HEIGHT OF FOR CLOSURE
CRISIS WHEN THIS PROGRAM WAS
IMPLEMENTED APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED HOMEOWNERS EACH MONTH WE
SEE FORECLOSURE NOTICES.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
MANY THIS HOMEOWNERS BECOME
TARGETED BY FRAUDULENT
FORECLOSURE CONSULTANTS WHO
ADVERTISE SOLUTIONS IN EXCHANGE
FOR COSTLY SERVICES THAT ARE
NEVER ACTUALLY RENDERED.
THIS INCLUDES FALSE CLAIMS OF
GUARANTEES THAT THE CONSULTANT
CAN STOP THE FORECLOSURE
PROMISES OF A NEW LOAN OR LOAN
MODIFICATION OF THAT INVESTOR
WILL BY THE HOME.
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND TO TWENTY
THIRTY THE PORTION OF THIS
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS ACCOUNT TO
COLLECT A SEVEN DOLLAR RECORDING
FEE FOUR NOTICES OF DEFAULT.
AND USE THOSE FEES TO ALERT
HOMEOWNERS THAT THEIR HOMES AND
FORECLOSURE EXPLAINED OUR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES ARM OF THE
LAW AND ENABLE THE COUNTY TO
PROVIDE FREE ENTRUSTED SERVICES
SUCH AS MORTGAGE COUNSELING.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAS RECEIVED OVER
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED FRAUD
COMPLAINTS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
WHICH HAS LED TO OVER ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN RESTITUTION.
TO HOMEOWNERS RETHINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH FOR OFFERING AT THIS BILL
TO ALLOW LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT WORK AND
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR WE'RE NOT GONNA
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WULD LIKE
TO BE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY PERSON LASSEN
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN RICH BRENNAN A FROM THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ECCLES COMPORT THIS
TIME.
WE NOW LIKE TO BEAR TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO'S OPPOSE IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
FOR LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL.
WITH A TO BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER.
MITCH HERTZBERG THANK YOU ON THE
ANALYSIS POINTS TO PROP TWENTY
SIX HAVE YOU DONE HAVE A LEGAL
OPINION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS VIOLATES PROP TWENTY SIX
WHICH IS NOT WHICH I'VE HAD TO
DEAL WITH MANY TIMES THAT IS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE AS TO
WHETHER.
THIS CONSTITUTES TAX.
SO SO BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WHEN I WAS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. FOR THE COUNTY WE
ACTUALLY WORK WITH OUR COUNTY
COUNCIL AND HAD OUTSIDE COUNSEL
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PROP.
TWENTY ISSUE AND TO MAKE A LONG
STORY SHORT WHAT WE DETERMINED
WAS THAT THE HAIRS OF THE FEE
THE LENDERS WITH REGARDS TO
FORECLOSURE.
AND THE HOMEOWNERS WITH REGARDS
TO THE AIDID NOTICES THAT THEY
WERE BOTH RECEIVING A DIRECT
BENEFIT.
FROM THESE FEES AND SO WE AGREED
THAT WE HAD OVERCOME THAT WE
LOOKED AT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPINION OF YOUR COUNTY BUT HAVE
WE LOOKED AT THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION BECAUSE I'VE HAD
TO DEAL WITH THIS.
HALF A DOZEN TIMES THIS YEAR AND
EVERY SINGLE TIME I'VE DEALT
WITH THEM ON ANY ISSUE THEY'VE
TOLD ME THAT PROP.
TWENTY SIX IS INVOKED IN THE
COST TO TO TAX ARLEDGE COUNCILS
TAKEN AN EXTREMELY CONSERVATIVE
VIEW.
ON WHETHER SOMETHING'S ATTACKS
OR NOT AT THIS THE EARTHQUAKE
DEAL I'VE HAD A BUNCH OF OTHER
STUFF IN DISCUSSING THE
WILDFIRES ALL OF THESE THINGS
WE'VE CONTINUALLY GOING BACK TO
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
HAVE WE CONSULTED WITH THEM AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THIS IT DEALS
WITH PROP TWENTY SIX THEY DID
NOT RAISE A FLAG WITH OUR LEAD
COUNSEL ON OUR SIDE [inaudible]
NO.
BUT I I JUST THINK THAT -- WE
GOT TO THE HOMEWORK BECAUSE I A
THIS IS GOING TO COME BACK TO
BITE US.
OR LITIGATED OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE BECAUSE I LITERACY
IS ON THE PHONE THIS WEEKEND
WHERE LAWYERS WERE TELLING ME --
WE HAVE AN OPINION ON THIS ON
ANOTHER ISSUE INVOLVING ANOTHER
SUB PUBLIC POLICY AREA.
AND WE THINK IT DOESN'T VIOLATE
PROP TWENTY SIX AND I SAID
NGUYEN HUMAN THING SO FAR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL HAS A
DIFFERENT OPINION.
YOU WANT TO LITIGATE THAT
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT OUR OUR
APPROACH IN OUR ANALYSIS IS
GOING TO BE INFORMED BY -- THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL SO I WOULD
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT WE ASK
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL THEIR
OPINION ON THIS -- GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
HAPPY TO DO THAT FOR THE
BACKGROUND WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
HERTZBERG WE'D LIKE TO BE TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS UP FROM
COMMITTEE MISTER VICE CHAIR.
AB TO PROVIDE A COUNTER -- YOU
YOU HAVEN'T HAD A CHALLENGE YET.
AXE WRECKED.
I DO NOT APPRECIATE BEING
INTERRUPTED.
BY THE SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
WELL I'M ASKING QUESTIONS MISTER
CHAIR.
AB DECORUM DAY THERE WE GO VICE
CHAIRS FIERY AND READY TO GO.
AREA.
I GET IT FROM SANTA CLARA.
WELCOME IS TO MOVE THANK YOU
WHEN SMITH TO ARE.
VERY PROFESSIONAL COMMITTEE.
LIVING THE DREAM LIVE IN THE
JURY HAVEN'T HAD AN ISSUE TODAY
NO ONE'S FILED A LAWSUIT.
TO THAT'S CORRECT CORRECT SO WHY
DON'T YOU JUST ELIMINATE THE
SUNSET.
THAT SET OF EXTENDING IT.
SO THAT WAS OUR OUR ORIGINAL
PLAN AND THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT
IN OUR IN OUR FIRST COMMITTEE ON
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE THAT --
REQUESTED THAT WE INCLUDE THAT
AT THE TENURE SUNSET.
THANK YOU.
BYE JUST ADD MISTER CHAIR.
THE THAT -- SO THIS IS THIS IS
ON THE ENHANCED -- PART OF THE
PROGRAM -- THERE WAS LEGISLATION
THAT WAS PASSED BY -- THAT WAS
PASSED AND SIGNED BY THE OWNER
BACK IN -- TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THAT ALSO THAT AND WE NEVER GOT
A QUESTION OR CHALLENGE WITH --
DEPART TWENTY SIX QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER SPEAKER
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
COLLEGE FOR THE BANTERING A
REALLY APPRECIATED MEANS LET ME
THINK OKAY THAT'S RIGHT EXACTLY
BECAUSE RUSSIA WERE ENTERED OVER
TO CENTRE BELL -- LIKE WE PASSED
A STATUTE.
I THINK IT WAS SB -- A TEN THAT --
CREATED THE HOMEOWNER BILL
RIGHTS.
AND IT MADE THE HOMEOWNER BILL
OF RIGHTS.
PERMANENT.
PREVIOUSLY THE HOMEOWNER BILL
RICE WAS A TIME LIMITED.
WITH THE SUNSET.
AND THEN WE PASSED A LAW THE
STATUTE -- TO MAKE IT A
PERMANENT.
LAW.
SO I KIND OF WONDER WHY I HAD
THE SAME QUESTION WHY IS THIS I
GUESS SHE EXPLAINED AT THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
AFTER THE AMENDMENT YEAH -- OKAY
SO THE HOMEOWNER BILL RIGHTS
WHICH IS THE SAME.
AREA OF LAW.
IS NOW A PERMANENT SO IT SEEMS
LIKE.
MAYBE IN THAT WAS A SENATE BILL
I MIGHT POINT OUT OR ARE BILL.
YEAH AND AND WE MIGHT.
LOOK AT THIS -- I DON'T KNOW
WEEK IT CREATE A CONFLICT WE
HAVE -- TO CONCURRENCE OR SOME
KIND OF CONCURRENCE PROCESS --
PERSONALLY I THINK IT SHOULD BE
A PERMANENT [inaudible]
LONG [inaudible]
YEAH.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MAKE
THEIR THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER ABOUT WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO THE VICE CHAIR.
ANOTHER SENATOR HERTZBERG HAS
LEFT THE ROOM [inaudible]
I'M.
HE MADE THE COMMENT THAT THIS
WAS A TAX.
I SEE THIS IS A FREE MAN I DON'T
SEE THIS IS A TAX IN MY CURRENT
YOU ARE CORRECT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IF THERE'S A MOTION AS
WELL WE ENTERTAIN THAT.
ALL RIGHT WITH THE MOTION AT BY
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM -- SAN
JOSE SENATOR PELL.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WE'RE GONNA ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE FOLLOW UP WITH
SENATOR BOWS OFFICE ON THE
ISSUES HE RAISED.
ON AND WOULD LIKE TO BE
OUTRAGEOUS INCLUDED IN THAT
CORRESPONDENCE AS WELL I WOULD
BE GREATLY APPRECIATED PLEASE
DON'T KNOW WHAT.
THE COMMITTEES SO MAYBE THAT
COULD BE SO WE CAN TALK ABOUT
OKAY.
YOU KNOW -- HOW STRONG FEW WHAT
HOW STRONGLY THE FEELING WAS
ABOUT LIMITING -- OKAY.
BUT THE THE ACTUAL.
SUBJECT WAS THE HOMEOWNER BILL
RIGHTS AND THAT WAS MADE
PERMANENT BY THE LAW PASSED AND
SIGNED INTO LAW BY THE GOVERNOR
SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER BELL IN --
IT WILL WORK WITH THE SOON TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE
INFORMATION OVER TO YOU AS WELL
IT'S IN THE WOMAN YOU DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO JUDICIARY.
SOMEONE JACK TO CLOSE I THINK
STAFF IN THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION MAKE
SURE WE GET CLARITY AROUND THE
ISSUES RAISED TODAY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
ABOUT DO PASSAGE ASSURING.
THE SAME JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI.
I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE AYE
BELL.
I HERTZBERG FURTADO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
YES I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HI.
I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE A MEDICINE WOMAN WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THIS OPEN JUST ALLOW
FOLKS AT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS JOBS GOOD TO SEE YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIVE WILL THEN
TAKE FILE ITEMS SEVEN WITH MISS
EGGMAN FILE ITEM FIVE IS THE
MEMBER CHEN.
FOCUSING ON ALL ISSUES ON ALARMS --
IN THIS IS THE ALARM COMPANY ACT.
THE NUMBE YOU HAVE A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL SO WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR TRUNCATED VERSION
OF YOUR PRESENTATION BOTH FROM
YOURSELF AS WELL AS YOUR WITNESS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
WELL -- IF THAT'S THE CASE I
HOME WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE SUPPORT
IN LIEU OF TIME -- IS HELD BY
THE SUPPORT WAS STARTED BY
ACCEPTING THE TITLE MINUTES FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
AND YOUR ANSWER QUESTIONS I'VE
TRIED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH USE ONE GIVES
A QUICK THIRTY SECOND.
OVERVIEW OF THE BILL AB TOLD ME
I WAS PASSED BY THAT IS ON ARM
COMPANIES LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY
TO OBTAIN OR YOU A LOCAL USE
PERMIT FOR THEIR CUSTOMERS
UNLESS OTHERWISE SPECIFIED.
A LOCAL ORDINANCE ALL ALL AB
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE IS TRYING TO
CALL PLEASE MAKE SURE WE DON'T
HOLD ON ONE CUP RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOMETHING WE DO NOT HAVE CONTROL
OVER.
A IN RECENT YEARS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE START USING
EDITION FINDS ARE LONG COMPANIES
IN CASE WERE NORMAL STRICKER BUT
BUT THE ALARM USER TO RENEW
THEIR ALONG.
WITH LOCAL CITY.
AGAIN HAVES FOR CHRISTMAS IF YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
ANSWERS THANK YOU SO MUCH SYSTEM
IT'S GOOD TO SEE SIR WE WELCOME
YOU.
YES SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESTAURANTS SMITH ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA ALARM ASSOCIATION THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL I'LL JUST
MAKE MYSELF AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS.
PEOPLE WERE GONNA ASK FOR FOLKSWHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TONY GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
OF AT T. SECURITY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH IS BECAUSE LET'S SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT?
HEARING SEE NINE WE NOW LIKELY
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ARE MOTION.
WE HAVE A QUESTION BY SENATOR
BELL -- I'M CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT
IS THE POSITION OF THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES OF CITY GOVERNMENTS.
A CLEAR FOR THAT ON THIS
PARTICULAR SO THE BILL.
YEAH A SENATOR BILL THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
INTRODUCED THE BILL WE WENT TO
THE LEGAL CITIES THE COUNTIES --
POLICE CHIEFS AND SHERIFFS -- TO
MAKE SURE THEY WERE -- FINE WITH
WHAT WE WERE PROPOSING AN IT WAS
ALL GOOD [inaudible]
THE BILL.
MOVE THE BILL ACTIVE
[inaudible]
YEAH LOOK IT UP LAST YEAR THERE
WOULD BE SO MUCH.
AND THIS IS A MOTION A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
IN THE REJECT CLOSE HOW ME AFTER
I VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS A MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR DO PASSES AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR MISS LANCHESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
HI.
WELL LIKE I DEL.
I HERTZBERG FURTADO.
HELLO HI NIELSEN.
THE SAID I WINNER.
YOU KNOW HI.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE BILL -- ON
CALL TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO HOLD ON
THANK YOU CHAD AGAIN SO MUCH IN
DECEMBER.
PLEASE IN GENERAL NOW MOVING
FORWARD ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
EXCUSE ME ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS -- FOCUSING ON PUBLIC
CONTRACTS AND LOCAL AGENCIES
THIS IS.
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO GET SAN
JOAQUIN AND STOCKED IN INVOLVED
IN A PROGRAM THAT.
WAS PROPER ADVICE IN THE WOMAN
CARILLO LAST YEAR WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR MISS EGGMAN AND FOR ALL OF
HER WORK YOU HAVE -- WE THOUGHT
WE HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT
WE'RE GONNA BE DO FULL
PRESENTATION WAS GOING TO SAY
YOU'VE DONE MY PRESENTATION A
THERE WE GO VERY MUCH SO ASSUME
THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE FOR THREE
MUCH -- AND GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY AND AS THE CHAIR
POINTED OUT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ADD SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY INTO AN EXISTING PROGRAM
THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR.
OF THE AND THE BILL THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR AND I LOOK
AROUND I SEE EVERYBODY HERE CAME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- FOR IT
WITH A WE ALREADY HAVE AN
EXISTING PROGRAM ONE A SMALL
BUSINESS CAN HAVE A 5% PREFERRED
TO TREATMENT FOR BIDDING
CONTRACTS FOR PROCUREMENT FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS -- THE BILL
LAST YEAR ADDED DISABLED
VETERANS AND SOCIAL ENTERPRISES --
AND THAT WAS FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND BASICALLY FOR FOR
AREAS IN THE BAY AREA AND IN A
LOS ANGELES AREA WE SIMPLY WANT
TO ADD A PILOT IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AS WELL -- THIS WILL
SUNSET AND IT ALSO ADDS A GRID
PROVIDES UP 27% FOR EACH NOT TO
EXCEED.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND IN TOTAL --
AND THIS AND IT IS ONLY
VOLUNTARY -- FOR COUNTIES IF
THEY WOULD LIKE TO DO IT -- WE
THINK IT JUST ADDS -- SMALL
BUSINESS SOCIAL ENTERPRISE AND
DISABLED VETERANS A MORE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
IN LOCAL PROCUREMENT AND I HAVE
DAVE JONES HERE WITH ME FROM THE
CITY OF STOCKTON SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AND OR COMMENTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS SOON AS YOU JONES
FORESHORES GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALIKE APPLY THE
AUTHOR -- THIS IS AS GOOD AS SHE
DID A FABULOUS PRESENTATION JUST
EXTENDS THE OFFER TO SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY IN THE CITY OF STOCKTON --
EVERYBODY HAS A HOUSING CRISIS
WE ALSO HAVE JOBS CRISIS IN
STOCKTON WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
JOBS AND STOCKTON WE THINK BID
PREFERENCES FOR THESE SPECIAL --
UNITS THAT ARE STRUGGLING AND
NEED A LITTLE BIT OF A HAND UP
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND WOULD
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS JONES
FANATIC TO OPEN UP FOR ANYONE
ELSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
LAST CALL I WOULD LIKE TO
RECEIVE WE HAVE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GLASCOFF PROPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE FIFTY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND OR A MOTION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION THE
BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY AS IN HER
TITLE THIS MOTION IS A DO PASS
TO THE FLOOR CINNAMON WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH IN COMMON WONDERFUL
ADVOCATE -- FOR HER HOME
DISTRICT WE ARE NOW GOING TO
TAKE ABOUT MOTION TO PASSAGE FOR
BY SOONER TITLE THIS THING JUST
A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
WARRIOR I MCGUIRE I'M MORE A LOT.
WELL LIKE I SAID THEY'LL.
THEY'LL GRANT HERTZBERG RICARDO.
THE TITLE AYE NIELSEN
[inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER WIENER HIGH.
KERN ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO VOCAL
CAN KEEP ROLE OPEN ALLOW MEMBERS
AT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE.
HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON RIGHT NOW.
CENTER TITLE ANYTHING YOU WANNA
[inaudible]
TALK ABOUT.
HE SAID THERE IS NO WAY EXACTLY
I KNOW.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL THIS WEEK YEAH.
BUT IS A GERMAN WE NOW HAVE OUR
AND NEXT AUTHOR HERE WE ARE
GRATEFUL.
THAT SHE IS COMING IN THIS IS AS
SOMEONE FRIEDMAN ON AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN FOCUSING ON ALL
ISSUES OF PLANNING AND ZONING.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SO WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION FOR BOTH
YOURSELF AS WELL AS THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MA'AM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS -- AB --
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN SEEKS TO CLARIFY
THAT IF THE COMMUNITY PLAN HAS
BEEN ADOPTED BY A CITY.
AND THEN IT'S CHALLENGED --
UNDER SYKORA AND A JUDGE ISSUES
A STAY ON THE PLAN BUT ANY
PROJECTS THAT WERE DEEMED
COMPLETE BY THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT EITHER APPROVED OR
OTHERWISE.
DEEMED COMPLETE CAN STILL
PROCEED AND THE ATTACHED TO THE
IDEA OF THE BILL IS THAT THESE
PROJECTS HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS THEY HAVE WORKED UNDER
WHAT AT THE TIME WAS A LEGALLY
BINDING THE GENERAL PLAN.
THEY SHOULDN'T NOW AFTER HAVING
INVESTED SOMETIMES MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS -- IN DOING THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS IN
GETTING ALL OF THEIR APPROVALS
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO GO FORWARD -- BECAUSE THEY
WERE YOU KNOW APPROVED BEFORE A
JUDGE ISSUED A STAY WE THINK
IT'S A SAYS IT'S CLEAR FINE --
WE THINK THAT IT'S IN KEEPING
WITH ON THE INTENT OF SEE C<c.cyan></c>
AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK IS
THE MOMENT.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE IT'S GOOD TO SEE ON
THE SECOND ROUND THE FORESHORES
ME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SELL
THE A SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI -- WE LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN -- WORK
ON THIS MEASURE AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEES -- ADVICE I WOULD
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE BILL
MAINTAINS AND SUPPORTS THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SECRET TO
DISCLOSE ALL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH AN
UPDATED COMMUNITY PLAN -- IN LOS
ANGELES THE LAND USE ELEMENT OF
THE GENERAL PLAN IS MADE UP OF
THIRTY FIVE INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY
PLANS MANY OF WHICH ARE OVER
TWENTY YEARS OLD.
AND VERY.
AND VERY OUTDATED -- TO CORRECT
THIS MIRROR CITY IS COMMITTED TO
UPDATING ALL OF THE PLANS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE'RE
DEDICATING LOTS OF MONEY AND
STAFF TO DO THIS -- AND THESE
PLANS WILL MEET -- THE LOCAL AND
STATE ENVIRONMENTAL
TRANSPORTATION THE STATE ABILITY
GOALS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
HE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SOMEONE
ASSUME YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING
THE MEASUREMENTS AS WELL YES I
WAS GOING TO SEND MY CLOTHES
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS NO YOU'RE OUT.
YOU'RE ALL GOOD WHAT WE ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL FOLKS IN SUPPORT FOR
SOME WRESTLING MEMBERS DAVID
JONES ABOUT THE CITY OF GLENDALE
STRONG SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK
YOU MISTER JONES THANKS FOR
HANGING WITH US GOOD MORNING
GERMAN MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD TO SEE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
KNOW LIKE BETTER DO A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT LAST CALL
FOR SUPPORT.
WE'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORTH THIS
TIME.
SO WE'RE GONNA BE COME TO THE
FRONT TABLE IF YOU DON'T MIND.
JUST WHAT ARE YOU DON'T WRITE
REAL QUICK A BRAND ALSO SEE A
CALIFORNIA -- WE'RE REFLECTING
ANALYSIS AS A POSTPOSITION BUT
WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS I'M
IN A POSITION.
WE'VE GIVEN THE OFFICE OF
AMENDMENTS OVERTIME IN A
CONVERSATION WITH ON THE WAY UP
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AS
WELL SO THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE AS YOU ARE A
SQUISHY IN BETWEEN.
YES ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A GRATEFUL.
LET ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
THAT MAYBE IN THE SQUISHY AREA
AND OR OPPOSE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HEARING SEENTHEM WITH A TO BE
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
LET ME TO SEE IF -- QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR MOTION YEAH -- ABOVE
THE MOVE THE BILL THEY JUST
COMMENTS -- OF THESE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGS GO FORWARD I'VE
AGAINST IMPORTANT BUILT -- I
WISH IT WERE STRONGER AND I KNOW
IN PAST ITERATIONS IT WAS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DID JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE -- IS NOT ALWAYS
FRIENDLY -- TO COMMONSENSE --
SEE QUIRK BILLS -- AND I YOU
KNOW I I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE HAVE
CERTAIN CERTAINTY WHEN THEY'RE
ENGAGING AND DEVELOPMENT.
I'M PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVE A
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION HOME --
HOUSING SHORTAGE THAT IS REALLY
STRANGLING THE STATE AND WE'VE
SEEN -- JUST YESTERDAY THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS NUMBERS WITH
HER -- IT'S IT IS -- JUST
UNBELIEVABLE HOW HOMELESSNESS IS
BY DOING AROUND THE STATE IN
THAT 71% OF HOMELESS PEOPLE ON
ARE NOT MENTALLY ILL AND DO NOT
ARE NOT ADDICTED TO DRUGS UNLIKE
THE STEREO TYPE THAT WE HEAR.
MOST ALMOST PEOPLE SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD HOUSING BECAUSE WE'VE
DONE SUCH  POOR JOB ALLOWING
HOUSING TO BE BUILT -- AND SO WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT -- SEQUEL
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT LAW BUT IF
YOUTO MAKE SURE THAT'S BEING
APPLIED IN A RATIONAL WAY IN THE
PEOPLE CAN RELY.
ON THESE PLANS AND ACTUALLY
BUILD HOUSING AND NOT HAVE THE
RUG PULLED OUT FROM UNDER THEM
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER
WOULD LIKE TO GET A SEAT PLEASE
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THE TECHNICAL QUESTION SINCE I'M
NOT A LAWYER MISTER CHAIR -- IF
[inaudible]
SOMEONE.
GOES TO A JUDGE AND ASKED FOR A
STATE [inaudible]
BUT THAT'S THEY CAN'T BE HONORED.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF GOING TO THE
JUDGE SO THE STATE IS NOT ON IT
AN INDIVIDUAL PROJECT THAT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT THIS IS A STAY ON
THE ENTIRE GENERAL PLAN.
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
PLAN HAS ALREADY GONE THROUGH IN
THIS CASE OF LOS ANGELES
MULTIPLE YEARS OF COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT.
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL HEARINGS.
EVERYTHING ELSE THEN THE PLAN
GETS ADOPTED LEGALLY THE PLAN IS
IN EFFECT.
A DEVELOPER GOES AND PUTS
FORWARD THEIR PROJECT MAYBE ALSO
DOES YEARS OF COMMUNITY MEETINGS.
THE PLAN IS APPROVED AT THAT
POINT A JUDGE LET'S SAY
SOMEONE'S NOW SUE THE GENERAL
PLAN THE JUDGE SAYS WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THE ENTIRE GENERAL PLAN
ON HOLD WILL THAT PROJECTS IS
ALREADY GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS
UNDER A LEGALLY BINDING PLAN.
WE THINK THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BUILD AT THAT POINT IF THEY ARE
DEEMED COMPLETE NOT IF THEY'VE
JUST SUBMIT THEIR APPLICATION TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY HAVE THEIR
ENTITLEMENTS.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
EVEN IF THE PLAN -- HUSBAND
STAYED BECAUSE THEY GOT CAUGHT
YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THE TIMING --
IN A CERTAIN PLACE AND WE DON'T
THINK THAT THEY SHOULD -- YOU
KNOW HAVE TO BEAR KIND OF THE
RESULT OF THAT GIVEN THAT DURING
THEIR APPROVAL PROCESS THE PLAN
WAS NOT STATE.
ANYTHING THAT CAME IN AFTER
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PROCEED.
GREAT EXPLANATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN I
APPRECIATED.
MR THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE ARE
MOVING ABOUT.
HELLO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE I'M JUST I REALLY
APPRECIATE ON SENATOR WINNERS
COMMENTS AND I WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE SEEING THIS BILL MOVES
THROUGH IT HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND IT'S GOTTEN BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
SO FAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SOMEONE MEMBERS THIS HAS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU SIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHY I'M MORE A LOT?
MORE LIKE AYE BELL.
BELL ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG.
RICARDO IT'S NOT ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WAITER.
WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
SOON WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE
BILL ON CALL AND ALLOW MEMBERS
AT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK THANK YOU COULD SEE YOU.
MEMBERS I AM GONNA NEED TO GO
VOTE IN EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR IT TO THE
FRONT.
SOME NEVER.
GOOD MORNING SIR IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
I I I APOLOGIZE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO TURN OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR
MORLOCKS SO I SEE THERE WE GO HI
DAY.
CAN NOW ON THIS FLOOR WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS -- IN I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE IS A MEMBER WHO'S
MADE AMENDMENTS COMING INTO
COMMITTEE -- IN REGARDS TO OF A
PROPERTY IS NO LONGER USED TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR HOMELESS
AND LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS THAT
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT ALSO
KNOWLEDGE THIS IN THE REFER HIS
WORK ON THIS BILL WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
GRATEFUL FOR THIS AT YUR
EFFORTS ANALYSTS IMPORTANT ONE
TO THE HOME TOWN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR HARD WORK WITH OUR STAFF ON
THIS -- PARTICULAR BILL.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO EST DISTRICT BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE OUR COMMITTEE
WITH MUCH NEED TOOLS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO
AUTHORIZES CITY OF MANTI COULD
YOU TRANSFER A GOVERNMENT OWNED
PROPERTY FOR LESS THAN MARKET
VALUE TO A LOCAL NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES RESOURCES TO HOMELESS
AND LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLING TO CONFRONT THE
HOMELESS CRISIS MANTECA AND
LOCAL NONPROFITS ARE DOING ALL
THAT THEY CAN TO ADDRESS THIS.
THIS PROPERTY WOULD SERVE AS A
GREAT CENTRAL LOCATION FOR THE
CITY AND IT NONPROFIT PARTNER TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES TO OUR
LOW INCOME AND HOMELESS
POPULATION.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF ALREADY A
DISSOLUTION.
THE AGING PROPERTY MUST BE SOLD
AT AUCTION AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FIVE TWO WOULD PROVIDE MEN TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO UTILIZE A
BUILDING THAT IS OTHERWISE A
VACANT FOR NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS.
TO PROVIDE CRITICAL RESOURCES TO
THE HOMELESSNESS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS MAYOR
BENJAMIN CAM.
TO THIS MATTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE FOR YOU -- I HAVE ACTUALLY
PERSONALLY BEEN WORKING ON THIS
PROJECT LONG BEFORE I A WAS
ELECTED AS MAYOR -- THE
COMMUNITY HAS THE HOMELESS ISSUE
THAT IT NEEDS TO DEAL WITH.
AND THE THIS BUILDING A SERVICE
THAT NEED WE HAVE -- NONPROFIT
INTERESTED IN MANAGING THE
PROJECT.
AND IT WILL PROVIDE MORE THAN
JUST A SHELTER THAT SHE WILL BE
A RESOURCE CENTER OR WE CAN
BRING IN COUNTY SERVICES A DEAL
WITH.
THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF BEING
HOMELESSNESS -- SO THE COMMUNITY.
THE RESIDENTS AS WE ARE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYOR CAN'T TO ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS MYLES LARSON I AM ON
THE BOARD OF ONE OF THE NON
PROFITS IN MANTECA THAT WORKS
CLOSELY WITH THIS POPULATION --
ALSO AN AREA PASTOR AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT OF AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO LARSON.
MY NAME IS RONALD FRANKIE ENEMA.
I BUT I'VE LIVED IN AND TAKE A
FIFTY NINE YEARS AND A LOCAL
REALTOR AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO YOU MISTER
THE FRANKIE FOR COMING.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ALL LINE UP
TO THE BACK OF THE ROOM.
AT THOSE WILL PLACER.
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE I JUST
HAD ONE QUICK QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMAN FLOOR OF WHY NOT
JUST MAKE IT A STATEWIDE BILL
WHEN WE JUST ALLOW.
SUCCESSOR.
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE.
TO SELL AT A DISCOUNT.
IT'S KIND OF CURIOUS I IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO LOOK INTO I KNOW LAST YEAR
HAS BEEN ABANDONED -- OF ONE OF
OUR LOCAL BUSINESS OR YOU KNOW
FACILITIES HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AREA DID SO THE SAME SITUATION
IT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK INTO WE
HAVE A LOT OF PROPERTIES THAT
ARE NOT BEING UTILIZED.
AND I THINK TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE ALL THOSE PROJECTS SHOULD
BE AT THE TABLE -- WHEN WE HAVE
PEOPLE READY WILLING TO SERVE
THE POPULATION CERTAINLY SOMEONE
IS LOOKING?
TO BRING TO CHALLENGE YOU YEAH
THANK YOU.
MAYOR CAN'T DO THINGS FOR
WORKING ON A MULTIPLE SERVICE
CENTER REALLY APPRECIATED THANK
YOU -- YOU'VE MADE AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY IF THE PROPERTY IS NO
LONGER USED TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
FOR HOMELESS AND LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AT THE PROPERTY HAS
TO BE SOLD AT FAIR MARKET VALUE.
WITH ANY REVENUES DISTRIBUTED
BACK TO TAXING ENTITIES ON A PRO
RATA BASIS THAT'S CORRECT WITH
IF RATE.
THEN A WE HAVE A MOTION DO
PASSED THE SENATE HOUSING
[inaudible]
MISS [inaudible]
WHEN [inaudible]
CHESTER.
THE CHOIR WARLOCK I LIKE AYE
BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG.
RICARDO RICARDO HI NIELSEN.
THE SAID AYE WIENER.
WIENER I FIVE ZERO THAT PASSES
BUT WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
FIGURE MUCH CENTER THANK YOU
READY.
THAT TAKES US NOW TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN CARILLO
WELCOME.
IF WE GET YOU AT THE TABLE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
IF WE GET YOU TO THE TABLE AS
QUICKLY AS WE POSSIBLY SAY THAT
THANK YOU.
YOU READY YOU WE ARE READY
WELCOME THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM VERY PROUD 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY WHICH WILL
BETTER EQUIP CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
PROTECT AND ENCOURAGE.
THE GROWTH OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THIS BILL WILL DIRECT THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH AND
COLLABORATING WITH STATE
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES GUIDELINES TO PROVIDE
ONGOING COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
SMALL BUSINESSES AS YOU ALL ARE
AWARE PLAN ESSENTIAL RULING
CALIFORNIA'S REGIONAL ECONOMIC
AN INDUSTRY SECTORS AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA WAS HOME TO
THREE POINT NINE MILLION.
SMALL BUSINESSES IN INDUSTRIES
SUCH AS RETAIL TRADE
CONSTRUCTION AND FOOD SERVICES.
SMALL BUSINESSES ALSO PROVIDE
CULTURE AND ECONOMIC CAPITAL IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AS THEY
OFFERED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND NEW JOBS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BE ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND LIVELIHOOD OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT THE STAIN THEIR
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES CAN BE
SEVERELY IMPACTED DUE TO
WIDESPREAD WIDESPREAD
NEIGHBORHOOD GENTRIFICATION
WHICH I'VE SEEN.
DIRECTLY IN MY OWN COMMUNITY AS
A RESULT OF GENTRIFICATION
COMMUNITIES MOST OFTEN ADJUST TO
THE RISING COST OF LIVING.
OF LIVING AND SMALL BUSINESSES
MONTH ABSORB THE SURGEON COST OF
RENT IN ADDITION TO CONTINUE AS
INCREASES.
IN THE BUSINESS START UP AN
OPERATING COST AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY WILL DIRECT OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO DEVELOP
GUIDELINES FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT REPRESENT BEST
PRACTICES TO PROTECT.
AND ENCOURAGE THE GROWTH OF
SMALL BUSINESSES BY JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SMALL
BUSINESSES CREATE JOBS STRIVE
INNOVATION AND STRAIN OUR
COMMUNITIES AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
WILL BETTER EQUIP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO SUPPORT THESE
VALUABLE BUSINESSES WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
WHAT EGGMAN TO SAY THANK YOU THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR IN A ROW OR SHE'S
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON SMALL
BUSINESS?
IT'S A PASSION OF HERS IN DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WE'D LIKE TO BETTER --
ENTERTAIN ANYONE WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE I JOIN US AT THE
MICROPHONE TO TIME.
OKAY FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
YOU'RE LIKELY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME.
ASK OFFER OPPOSITION.
LIKELY TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE RECEIVING THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THEY ALSO
A COMMOTION FROM THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL.
WITH MOTION BY CENTER TITLE
THINK IS MUCH CENTER TITLE.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE TO
SIGN.
THE MOTION IS A TO PASS A
PREPARATIONS.
SO THE WOMAN JACK TO CLOSE.
YOU KNOW SMALL BUSINESSES PLAY A
HUGE ROLE IN THE FIFTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AS THEY DO
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AS WE SEEN RUNS CONTINUE TO RISE
ONE THING THAT WE DON'T HAVE OUR
TEN A PROTECTIONS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND SO THEY CONTINUE TO FAIL OR
CLOSE AND THEY EMPLOY PEOPLE
FROM OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IS DOING
EVERYTHING IT POSSIBLY CAN TO
PROTECT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME WOMAN
WERE SO UPSET THAT I JUST
BECAUSE OUR GOES -- TO IS -- IN
YOUR OFFICE SO -- SHE'S
WONDERFUL I'M AND BUT AS I SEE
ASK I AND AGAIN VERY LUCKY TO
HAVE HER IN THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ASSUMING YOU DO A
FANTASTIC JOB.
WE DO HAVE A DO PASSED TO
PREPARATIONS MOTION THE FOUR BY
CENTER TITLE IS IN CHESTER VOCAL
PLEASE WIRE HI WHERE I'M MORE
LONG.
WELL LIKE I BILL.
NO I HERTZBERG FOR TOMORROW.
YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
SIX CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
JAVASCRIPT KINGS YOU.
AS A GERMAN.
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE EACH AND
EVERY MEMBER WHO IS HERE.
SEC WITH THE EXCEPTION OF MYSELF.
ON EACH OF THE BILLS BUT WE'RE
GOING TO DOUBLE CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ALL SQUARE --
ENGAGE ADHERE ACP YOU CAN JUST
GIVE IT IS ABOUT SIXY SECONDS
WILL BE A SQUARE BODY UP
.
I BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA NEED
SENATOR NIELSEN AN ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE SEVEN AND WE'RE CHECK IN
EVERYONE ELSE
.
CENTER PART OF WINTERS.
YES.
IN YOUR IN THE VICE WHICH WILL.
CENTER MCGUIRE ON RIGHT.
WE'RE JUST GOING WITH THE SEVEN
THIS IS AN NIELSEN I MISSPOKE
IT'S JUST AN ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN I APOLOGIZE.
I DON'T NUMBER SEVEN CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO VOTE THIS IS
A MOTION TO PASS OF THE FLOOR.
MESSENGER SERVIC PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE. SIX ZERO VOTE.
NIELSEN THANK YOU SO MUCH PRESS
WORK TODAY IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE SIR.
THANK YOU JIM ARE NOW TO BE
OPENING UP ITEM NUMBER NINE
MAYBE SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO THIS
HAS A DO PASS TO SENATE HOUSING.
MISSING JUST REVIEW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WARRIOR HIGH
WIRE I HERTZBERG. SIX ZERO WHEN
HE THE ROLE OPEN.
CENTER HERTZBERG IS.
HOPEFULLY IN ROUTE.
CONGER NAILS CAN BRING THE TASER
UP THE CAN DOWN IF WE NEED
.
TO NO YOU'RE GOOD.
WHICH IS SENATOR WE'RE GONNA BE
[inaudible]
ALL WE HAVE A FEW WE'RE GOING TO
ADD YOU ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT
AND NINE SO LET'S START WITH
ITEM NUMBER FOUR THIS IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY CURRENT ENJOYS A
FIVE ZERO VOTE.
THE CENTRIST.
THE FINAL VOTE IS FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT AND
WE'RE CLOSING IT DOWN FOR NOW
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM FIVE
CURRENTLY ENJOYS HIS SIX YEAR
VOTE.
VISIT.
DO YOU PASS IS.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY I NEVER.
SIX OKAY I REMEMBER FIVE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE AT THIS-ENJOYS A DO PASS AS A MANAGER
THE FLOOR MOTION CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE THE SAME
GESTURE.
HERTZBERG. SEVEN ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SIX A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THIS
IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED YOU
JUDICIARY.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX YEAR VOTE
WAS LANCASTER HERTZBERG.
FIRST BIRTHDAY SEVEN ZERO VOTE
PEDALS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B..
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE THIS IS A
DO PASS TO THE FLOOR MOTION
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO MISS
LANCHESTER.
HERTZBERG GUY SEVEN ZERO VOTE
THAT BILL IS THAT WERE CLOSE THE
ROLE MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO MORE
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS.
MOTION CURRENT ADDRESS A SIX
YEAR VOTE WAS LANCASTER
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG. SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILLS THAT WERE CALDERON
FINALLY A FILE ITEM NINE AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE HOUSING
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
MISSING CHESTER.
HERTZBERG LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THAT THAT ENJOY THE SEVEN ZERO
VOTE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WHERE THAT BILLS THAT WERE CLOSE
THE ROLE?
WE WILL SEE YOU NEXT WEEK I
WOULD PLAN ON IT TWO TWO AND A
HALF HOUR.
MAYBE OF THE THREE HOUR HEARING
NEXT WEEK -- AND THEN EVERYTHING
ELSE WILL BE ABOUT TWELVE HOURS
FOR THE REST OF THE MONTH.
SO -- THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MAJORITY
LEADER IN WE'LL SEE YOU NEXT
WEEK MANAGER.
YEAH